we all know Detroit's in trouble a
bankrupt city full of crumbling houses
abandoned factory buildings and a fast
dwindling population but while the
politicians unions and investors slug it
out in bankruptcy court and grasp for
their share of what little cash the city
has left ordinary citizens are left to
make a do in a city with no functioning
government this is what happens when
people are left to their own devices
this is anarchy in Detroit the word
Anarchy is often interpreted as chaos
and danger and hooded figures throwing
bombs into windows but really it means
no rulers the most chaos in Detroit has
been created by government
this is fireweed universe city an
artistic community of anarchists
squatting in a block of abandoned houses
they have Gardens murals bicycles even
electricity their bill is too high to
Comcast bills so they they didn't pay us
I don't know there's no internet we met
up with a group called free Detroit here
in firewood University as self-described
libertarians they don't endorse
squatting but they plan on buying up
swaths of Detroit's dirt cheap real
estate to create tiny libertarian
enclaves it's a group of individuals who
have the intention of purchasing
property all in one densely localized
area to move together and create a
counter economy and basically operate
outside of the city's government is
based upon survival when the inhibitions
and the regular market becomes so great
people have to find alternative methods
some people have a different philosophy
and decide to squat and even though that
I don't philosophically agree with that
I see um the community is actually still
welcoming them here because things have
just been that bad will there be an
opportunity for Detroit or even pockets
of Detroit to become little libertarian
enclaves or you know free market Free
People type locations where people who
enjoy peaceful voluntary association can
congregate the answer is yes absolutely
Detroit has little pockets of its own
that could become more libertarian if
given the opportunity you see a lot of
development in Corktown you see a lot of
development that's trying to move
forward in places like Hamtramck but
they need more latitude from the city to
really accelerate that vision much of
the development that has been promised
to Detroit has been money going from
this politician to this politically
connected crony I think what's really
going to help the city recover is for
individuals who live here to take action
self responsibility and working hard and
and seeing these in the market and going
and fulfilling those and through all
through voluntary exchange